je suis arrivé en sixième avec mes amis
de cm2 puis je me suis vite intégré au
collège je me suis fait des amis en 6e
dont un groupe de 2 3 qui se
connaissaient déjà depuis la maternelle
donc on avait dû former un petit groupe
de quatre filles et petit à petit je
perdais mes amis de cm2 mais pas dans le
sens où je m'éloigne edel vous arrêter
de me parler ils ne voulaient plus me
parler mais je me disais que c'était la
vie et avait changé de voie là j'avais
donc j'avais pas forcément prêter
attention ils mettaient pas forcément
demander pourquoi sauf qu'à un moment
j'ai commencé à mettre à dos ses deux
autres filles de notre petit groupe de
quatre degrés et cette fille qui restait
avait toujours été là pour me dire que
que c'est pas grave que l air et serait
toujours là et pour me dire que fallait
pas que je prête attention et moi très
jeunes parce que à cet âge là j'avais
encore dix ans je m'étais dit que bah
c'était une vraie amie et que c'est pas
grave je n'ai même pas me demander
pourquoi une pause faisait la tête parce
que ça me ce serait me prendre la tête
et du coup j'étais resté avec cette
fille là qui a pendant très longtemps
enfin très longtemps pendant quelques
semaines a vraiment été là pour moi et
un stage était encore très jeune donc
j'avais pas forcément de téléphone
j'avais seulement snapshot pour
communiquer avec mes frères et soeurs
qui était à l'étranger et j'avais
demandé à mes parents si je pouvais la
joue t elle est seulement elle donc il
avait accepté et donc on parlait sur les
réseaux sociaux puis elle a commencé en
soirée un vent de l'histoire à me dire
qu'elle voulait plus être amis avec moi
donc je suis vraiment inquiété en
demandant ce que j'avais fait et elle me
dit que j'avais fait quelque chose de
grave mais elle n'arrivait jamais à me
dire ce que j'avais fait et elle a
commencé à me dire que de façon j'étais
qu'une cassos qu' il fallait que je
rentre chez moi que qu'elle voulait plus
parler avec moi et donc j'en ai parlé à
mon grand frère et il m'a dit de la
bloquer donc je les bloquer je suis un
peu cancer qui est derrière et josé oui
et
le lundi je suis retourné au collège est
vraiment elle a fait comme si de rien
n'était elle m'a sauté dans les bras et
m'a dit salut comment ça va enfin rien
où elle m'a jamais reparler de ça et je
m'étais dit que c'est pas grave c'était
la seule amie qui me restait je l'aimais
vraiment alors je passerai à autre chose
avait dû passer une mauvaise soirée où
je sais pas et donc je l'avais pardonner
par rapport à ça ce qu'au fur et à
mesure du temps elle commençait à me
dire tout ça en face en dix ans
aujourd'hui était vraiment mal habillé
tagro si tu es vraiment moche
aujourd'hui où tu as fait quelque chose
parce que là ça m'a pas ou ce genre de
choses mais elle me disait après que
c'était pour mon bien qu elle voulait
juste en tant qu'ami m'aider et me
protéger et donc bah j'ai rien dit pour
moi c'était la première fois que j'avais
de vrais amis avant j'étais encore trop
jeune donc je m'étais dit que bah
c'était sa jetée comme ça qui est ça
arrive à tout le monde c'est ça les amis
sauf qu'un jour elle a commencé à me
dire qu'en fait elle voulait plus du
tout être amis avec moi et elle ne
traîne est plus avec moi ou quand elle
venait avec moi c'était seulement pour
m'insulter et me rabaisser et là c'était
des insultes comme insulte bat déjà le
meur a baissé par rapport à mon physique
elle disait que j'étais grosse à ce
moment là j'avais les cheveux courts à
la garçonne gt40 quand j'étais un garçon
manqué puis ensuite elle me disait que
j'étais une [ __ ] que fallait que
j'aille mourir que je méritais personne
dans ma vie enfin tout ce genre de
choses toutes les insultes qu'on connaît
tous enfants s'étaient jamais saint
pacôme bnc ça et donc je me suis vite
renfermé sur moi-même et j'ai dis donc à
ma famille que elle ne voulait plus être
mon ami parce qu'à ce moment là c'était
que ça mais c'était quoi la raison là
bas eh ben j'ai toujours cherché à
comprendre mais elle n'a jamais su me
donner de raison en fait a dit que
j'avais fait quelque chose de grave mais
quand le site c'est pourquoi elle n'a
jamais quand j'essaie de savoir qu'est
ce que j'avais fait grave alors oui mais
pas à me dire et je cherche pas tous ont
tu mérites pas tu ne mérites pas elle
tournait toujours autour du pot alors il
paraît que la d'envoi ce soir car à vous
avez les rangs en forme nous raconter
très bien l'histoire mais faute mal-être
devient de plus en plus physique puisque
vous avez débat vous avez beaucoup de
mal mal de ventre dizaines de verrues
plein les mains qui ont fait ça c'est
parce que du coup c'est à dire qu'ils
vont vous angot ci est tellement c'est
ça parce qu'en fait j'ai essayé d'en
parler et ma famille m'a dit que c'était
rien l'établissement me m'a pris en
charge on m'a demandé qui était cette
personne ce qui se passait
et quand j'en ai parlé à l'établissement
ça faisait déjà deux mois que ça dure et
donc il ya vraiment des choses concrètes
j'avais vraiment une trentaine de
personnes autour de moi j'avais peur
j'avais déjà mal au ventre et elle voir
cela aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
et bah c'était avec commencé parce que
ça commençait sur snapsan n'a jamais
rien d'autre voilà ça s'est arrêté après
vous l'avez bloqués de par tout un stade
a partout donc voila et donc je
m'enferme aux toilettes pour pleurer et
vraiment j'avais vraiment peur et du
coup se passait vraiment des choses
concrètes donc j'ai pu en parler à mes
surveillants qui m'ont dit qu'ils
feraient quelque chose mais en fait ils
m'ont jamais rien fait quand il croisait
après ipc la tête
vous avez ont été renvoyés de votre
collège s'était jugé trop dérangeante
pour la direction parce que du coup donc
tout ça ça a duré pendant huit mois et
donc à la fin mai où moi je m'étais dit
que fallait que je fasse quelque chose
parce que ça pouvait plus durer comme ça
en fait
et l'idée m'était passé puis quelques
quelques mois plus tard donc créé se
faire dans le même établissement que moi
s'est suicidé là je m'étais dit que non
il y avait eu moi il y avait 8 et tout
pouvait plus y avoir quelqu'un qui
mouraient à cause du harcèlement
scolaire et donc j'ai créé une
association contre ça et le collège n'a
pas du tout aimé donc j'entendais tout à
l'heure vous disiez que c'était
inadmissible de demander à un élève de
changer mais moi on ne m'a même pas
demandé rien lors de marées inscriptions
au quatrième on m'a dit que non j'étais
pas sensé me reste aux a créé une
association c'est ça avec la maman de
christopher avec l'allemand christopher
kas surfeurs qui s'était suicidé on a
appris que c'était parce que j'avais
créé une association et que donc ça
faisait mauvaise image à l'établissement
et donc je n'ai même pas été acceptée
j'ai même pas eu le choix
c'est au final ça s'avère être la
meilleure chose pour moi parce qu'après
je me suis reconstruite et je suis
devenu la personne que je suis devenu
aujourd'hui et ça m'a encore plus mise
en colère sur fait de dire que ce top
c'est tout mais parce que coco vous
raconter l'histoire ici tôt la table on
le voit on a eu un témoignage incroyable
de la part de de karine est serré qui
nous a nous a tous se plonger dans un
désarroi
ça avait pu voir chez vous là je suis
sûr que les téléspectateurs se disent
bon c'est ça va cesser plus supportable
le harcèlement qu'a subis kiara mais ça
vous arrange et psychologiquement ça m'a
vraiment détruite à ce moment là j'avais
l'impression d'être d'être nulle jeu
même utile et pendant dix mois mais
est-ce que vous avez essayé de plus par
l'a7 personnel voir celer quand même des
pouvoirs elle voulait vous lâchez pas et
c'était à chaque fois et jallet
m'enfermer dans les toilettes puis elle
elle trouvait des moyens ou là mais des
amis devant la porte des toilettes à
dire ankara elle est vraiment grosse
alors oui c'est vraiment une [ __ ] pour
que j'entende comme si je me sens elle
savait pas que j'étais là alors qu'elle
savait très bien j'ai fait une tentative
de suicide
des vrais débutent les vacances de
décembre annonce à massa m'a vraiment
détruites et là aujourd'hui j'ai de
parler tout ça d'aider les jeunes à
votre ville soyez toujours ça ça me
permet de nous reconstruire mais mes ccc
une image jeu j'arrive à être heureuse a
parlé tout ça à j'arrive
mais j'ai toujours quelque chose en moi
qui ai détruit j'ai pas confiance en moi
je me trouve toujours moche ou bronze
par rapport à tout ce qu'elle m'a dit
quand j'arrive enfin à me trouver belle
je repense à ces mots dans ma tête je
j'ai du mal à faire confiance en
l'adulte ou même en les ja je suis
toujours détruite à l'intérieur du temps
c'est important de pas sous-estimer ce
genre de petit harcèlement alors on a eu
un été chargé
affligeant avec un enfant qui se fait
tabasser qui a des couilles kalana ina
tél moi je les souvenirs d'une petite
fille que j'ai vu qu'ils étaient dans un
collège parisien dans le centre de paris
donc c'est quelque chose qui touche tout
le monde pas forcément les aides dont on
parle dans les banlieues cmn dans un
collège élitiste on a des harceleurs et
j'ai cette petite fille de 11 ans qui à
terre ceux là bas bruit c'est à dire que
toute la journée on mettait des coups de
pieds dans sa chaise on le disait rien
et donc à pété les plombs et qui du coup
avait des hallucinations et je les
retrouvais dans sa chambre prostré à
devoir l'envoyer aux urgences
pédiatriques voir un psychiatre
tellement ça a eu un impact
moi je suis papa j'ai trois enfants est
désormais ma crainte c'est pas que les
enfants rater l'école c'est qu'ils se
fassent harceler on en est là remarque
en ce mois d'avril que désormais en
année la rédac est là où je vous en veux
c'est qu'au début je me dis la
responsabilité elle est multifactorielle
tournay responsable
on a les parents nous et je pense qu'il
faut poser au aux enfants la question
est ce qu'on embête à l'école parfois on
oublie leur peau bien sûr c'est vrai ça
et même s'ils ne le sont pas le jour ils
le sont vous avez ouvert une porte qui
fait que peut-être ils parleront et qui
vous qui dirait le champ centre et sert
excellence une simple question sujet
2 2 dans deux secondes on vous a proposé
quelque chose de très simple les
receveurs on les vire j'aimerais juste
qu'on sache clairement que le nom la
boue dans la boue par la grande majorité
dans la grande major sami anan sinon la
grande nom dans la grande majorité des
cas on a deux on a deux exemples
dramatiques dramatique de l'argent voit
régulièrement désemparé laissait bien
que chaque fois alors j'en vois on l'a
vu on changer de collège
on a fait changer le risque bien d'avoir
les dents face à lyon le numéro 20 bien
les jean michel blanquer lâche les
piranhas voilées qui accompagnent les
enfants et qui s'occupe des enfants
harcelés avec vous la plus d'urgence là
dessus vous êtes là vous êtes n'est pas
totalement de bonne foi
vous le savez très bien c'est que ces
témoignages la sont inacceptables
impensable ne doivent plus se reproduire
il faut les montrer il faut que les gens
prennent conscience de ça et vous savez
très bien que dans la très grande
majorité des cas yade il ya une écoute
il ya des sanctions
les harceleurs se font même pas partie
s'est terminée au jour michel blanquer
ailleurs ailleurs un enfant on ferme les
yeux ça n'existe d'ailleurs non violence
déborder soler ce leur manque de moyens
voir je vais jeter de l'argent on s'est
suffisamment d'impôts pour qu'on
s'occupe correctement nos enfants c'est
où adrien à l'attaqué michel blanc caire
a par ailleurs présenté un plan de lutte
contre les violences dans les
établissements où il ya notamment des
dispositions pour écarter les les
les agresseurs les harceleurs des
établissements il ya des agresseurs des
arts soeur qui passe évidemment conseil
de discipline qui se font également un
blâme
j'ai ces choses à côté
ne veut pas ce genre de mauvaise
réputation n'empêche jamais en cela en
cela je peux vous rejoindre et c'est
quand je parle de libération de parole
et qu'il ya un an faut briser la loi du
silence ça vaut aussi pour ça et
effectivement faut que tout le monde
sorte de sang mais ne fasse à des sujets
complexes comme ça pas papa de près de
caricatures va être est inachevée le
seul à devoir de laisser eric naulleau
faire sonner monsieur aussi ah oui je
veux pas je veux pas vous accablez
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas le beau rôle
mais j'entends les deux témoignages en
temps ce que vous avez à proposer il ya
une impression de déconnexion totale
c'est à dire que vous ne prenez pas en
compte l'urgence de la chose je crois
plus fondamentalement qu'on juge l'état
d'un pays à l'état de son école l'école
est devenue un lieu de souffrance avec
les suicides d'enseignants et avec le
fléau du harcèlement scolaire
comment se fait-il que ça soit pas
l'ultra priorité nationale et il ya un
triptyque il y a éducation répression il
y à détection est ce que il y a dans ce
plan une détection globale c'est à dire
sur le modèle de la visite médicale est
ce que quand on passe une visite
médicale pas forcément un bon souvenir
scolaire pour nous tous est ce que en
plus sûr à un questionnaire aux sigles
pour essayer le dollar au maire des
médecins qui non seulement examine
l'état physique des enfants mais qui
détecte de manière systématique
l'avicca dollars serait pose la droite
actions des professionnels induit
implique cet aspect repérage des
formations et voulez que je vous dise
plus largement la du harcèlement
scolaire
sur la question des maltraitances lens
fait aux enfants souvent par dans un
cercle intrafamiliales l'éducation
nationale est le premier pourvoyeur des
informations préoccupantes
donc oui les professionnels de
l'éducation nationale oui les
infirmières scolaires peuvent détecter
celles généralement qui signale quand il
ya des formes de maltraitance alors
pourquoi il essaie bienvenue en ont et
vont générer des avantages et des lieux
le chiffre alors qu'est ce qui se passe
mais écoutez je sais c'est un sujet qui
est appréhendé par la société depuis
ouais oui c'est récent c'est serré la
vis tankan méchant rembauché l'esab
servières et des matériaux excusez moi
un phénomène de cette ampleur là je veux
dire ça ne ce oui je l'admets c'est pas
sur un claquement de doigts que ça se
résout est je pense une fois encore que
donc on a un gouvernement qui investit
sur le sujet qui a pris ce plan qui est
très concret qui donne des outils qui
donne des outils à l'ensemble des
personnes qui peuvent intervenir des
outils des entreprises pionnières que
d'aller à les présidents h mais des
professionnels les élèves même les
parents qui doit être aussi sensibles à
ces questions parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous ça soit sur ce sujet là même
sa question des violences
plus largement il faut en parler à ses
enfants mais j'étais gamin de 4 et 7 ans
je leur parle de violence sexuelle je
leur parle de leur corps je leur parle
de la notion de consentement de leurs
rapports au corps il faut qu'on ait nous
en tant que parent aussi le courage de
parler de ces choses là dès le plus
jeune âge
je vais annoncer bientôt un plan de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants d'ici une dizaine de jours
on va renforcer la sensibilisation des
enfants à tous ces sujets la baie la
dernière année de maternelle parce que
c'est dès ce moment là qu'il faut qu'il
faut parler très sincèrement on c'est un
sujet complexe
on ne nie pas ça il ya une véritable
volonté de trouver des solutions
concrètes je veux dire où peuvent on
peut partir dans une grande envolée
faire des grands discours
nous ce qu'on espère dans les rues mais
malgré ses dix ouvriers d eux n'ont
elles rien j'ai dû me concret j'ai
investi
résultat une fait d'améliorer la
situation
on s'inspire on on s'inspire ont plus de
pays et vous répondez pas sur la
s'inspirant de pays en s'inspirant de
pays qui ont affronté le sujet là il a
répondu la diction affronter ce soir
elle a freiné avant nous et qui ont
réussi et vidéos saladerie attaqué ali
jes de lorsque on va on va devoir
laisser eric naulleau faire sont au fond
démission s'il vous plaît ce que je vois
c'est que papa la vidéosurveillance mais
je crois plus à l'humain c'est la
technique mais si laurent wauquiez
juste il ya des problèmes qui veut
mettre des caméras dans les bus
scolaires
mais enfin au royaume uni ça marche à
merveille à munich face à l'ampleur du
phénomène
je veux dire tout ça suffit a dit yves
toute expérimentation est bonne et ben
ali